le silence
commençons par ce silence mais pas
n'importe quel silence
le silence judiciaire
de ce silence judiciaire je pourrais
vous parler pendant des heures de
celui qui se fait lorsque la cour le
tribunal entre en salle d'audience
du silence qui s'impose face à la
douleur humaine
du silence assourdissant de certains
accusés dont on voudrait soit qu'ils
clament leur innocence soit qu'ils
reconnaissent les faits et qui ne
parlent pas
aussi gênant soit il
ce silence est essentielle
il offre à la justice à ses acteurs un
temps serein loin de tout ce qui
bourdonnent sans cesse à nos oreilles
mais face à ce silence
il y à notre sujet la parole
la parole judiciaire
cette parole judiciaire c'est celle des
justiciables bien sûr qu'ils viennent
dans les tribunaux former leurs demandes
donner leurs arguments ils disent leur
vérité
cette parole judiciaire c'est celle
aussi des témoins des experts dont les
mots les avis peuvent être décisifs
cette parole judiciaire c'est celle
aussi des professionnels du droit les
avocats les procureurs les juges
ils plaident ils requièrent
il décide
leurs paroles dans l'arène judiciaire
elles s'échangent elle se confrontent
souvent
elles se grandissent parfois aussi
et vous le savez sans doute il suffit
d'un mot pour faire changer le cours
d'un procès et c'est encore plus vrai en
matière criminelle ou devant la cour
d'assises seul ce qui aura été dit
content pour fonder l'intimé conviction
alors la parole judiciaire c'est
justement convaincre
et pour convaincre il faut trouver ce
qui fait sens chez l'autre comment mieux
le dire que jean denis bredin qui disait
plaidé
c'est écouter celui qui écoute
mais au delà de convaincre
donné de la voix en matière judiciaire
c'est aussi tenté de donner du sens
à des événements qui en manquent
cruellement d'apparence
donner du sens à des découvertes parce
qu'un adn d'un cheveux une trace une
empreinte
cela ne veut rien dire si on inscrit pas
dans un récit que l'on veut conforme à
la vérité que l'on défend
l'appareil judiciaire c'est justement
aussi défendre défendre une thèse celle
d'un homme celle d'une femme pour un
avocat défendre toute la société pour le
ministère public
alors il ya un flot de paroles dans les
tribunaux et dans ce flot de paroles
on retient surtout celle des ténors du
barreau et il est vrai que par leur ton
par leurs mots ils nous marquent et il
marque aussi notre histoire
les voix de robert badinter de gisèle
halimi sont de notre culture nationale
bien sûr
mais la voix des juges des procureurs
se fait aussi de plus en plus entendre
au-delà même de l'arène judiciaire
nous n'hésitons plus ou presque a donné
de la voix pour
témoigner notre action pour dire nos
décisions parfois même pour les défendre
c'est une révolution
et c'est de cette révolution dont je
propose de vous parler en quelques mots
des enjeux qui vont avec et comment
mieux voulait faire ressentir quand vous
mettant en situation
mesdames et messieurs vous êtes à
présent juge ou procureur
madame la procureure
monsieur le procureur un fait dramatique
vient de se commettre
un enfant a été enlevé sur la voie
publique dans des circonstances
hautement suspecte
votre réaction première
elle est naturelle et humaine c'est
l'inquiétude comme toutes et tous
mais tout de suite il ya le
professionnalisme chez vous vous vous
rendez sur place vous saisissez le bon
service d' enquête et vous fait
diligenter les investigations
vous repartez
il est 2 heures après l'événement et
votre téléphone sonne vous pensez et
madame la procureure au premier compte
rendu des enquêteurs non ce sont les
journalistes ils vous appellent déjà
parce que monsieur le procureur les
chaînes d'information en continu ont eu
connaissance de ce qui s'est produit
est très vite l'ordre public est sur la
brèche de fausses informations
commencent à circuler et tous les
principes essentiels sont bafoués
notamment par les médias qui désigne
déjà un présumé coupable
alors même le procureur vous avez un
choix à faire parce que la loi vous
offre un choix vous avez le droit de
parler ou de vous taire
mais monsieur le procureur en savez-vous
as assez pour ne pas risquer d'être
contredit dans la suite de l' enquête
madame la procureure n'allez-vous pas
par vos mots ce que vous allez choisir
précipité la disparition des preuves
précipité la fuite du suspect pire
précipité le sort de cet enfant
alors quoi
choisiriez-vous de ne pas parler de vous
taire mais dans ce cas vous d'informer
pas vun apaisé pas le trouble à l'ordre
public et vous laisser les médias
allaient trouver ailleurs des
informations qui tu as cherché et trouvé
des sources hasardeuse
alors madame le procureur vous allez
faire le choix de parler
mais pour parler il vous faut des
informations
fiables
or elles sont nécessairement parcellaire
elles sont nécessairement instable mais
vous choisissez celles qui sont juste à
ce moment là monsieur le procureur pour
parler il vous faut justement choisir
les bons mots ceux qui ne vont pas
choquer l'opinion publique ceux qui ne
vont pas trahir la vérité parce que vous
savez une chose c'est que ce que vous
allez dire sera aux yeux de tous la
vérité est qu'il n'ya dans l'arène
médiatique
aucun appel aucune voie de recours
et vous savez aussi que c'est toute
l'institution ensuite qui peut vaciller
sous le poids de vos mouvements
et ses choix de mot vous les faites
alors que vous continuez à mener l
enquête bien sûr alors que vous
continuez à mener des centaines d'autres
enquêtes et à ce moment là vous sentez
lourdement que la faiblesse des moyens
que vous avez dénoncé de manière inédite
dans une tribune récemment ne vous êtes
pas
mais il est temps de prendre cette
parole
vous choisissez de faire une déclaration
à la presse cela signifie que vous allez
parler mais que vous n'accepteriez que
vous n'accepterez aucune question et
vous le dit aux journalistes il n'y aura
pas de question à la fin de cette
déclaration
et cette déclaration vous l'a fait avec
les mots que vous avez choisi avec un
ton serein parce que vous êtes
parfaitement formés par l'école de la
magistrature le faire
et vous aimeriez partir de cette salle à
la fin dans un calme respectueux des
mots que vous avez dit mais non vous
quitter cette salle sous le flot des
questions des journalistes parce que les
journalistes tentent toujours
et lorsque vous regagnez votre bureau
vous vous demandez quel sera l'effet de
votre communication et vous regardez
les réseaux sociaux
sur ces réseaux sociaux vous constatez
que depuis les faits d appel à la traque
sauvage se sont multipliées vous
constaté aussi que les avis sur votre
parole sont prompts ils sont vifs que
chacun y donnent de la voix égalité et
que beaucoup dépasse les limites de
l'acceptable il dit sur ces réseaux
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus loin que ce
qu'il oserait dire en vrai
au passage
vous remarquez sur ces réseaux sociaux
que certains de vos collègues juges
procureurs ils sont 6 expriment en
mettant en indiquant qu'ils sont juge ou
procureur mais en faisant le choix de
parler sous pseudonyme
et vous constatez alors que la
protection que leur offre ce pseudonyme
l'anonymat les pouces manifestement a
manqué à leurs premières règles
déontologiques
alors vous pour l'avenir vous ne
fermeraient pas les yeux sur ces réseaux
sociaux parce que peut-être de manière
travesti vous pouvez y sentir le pouls
de la société ce qui bat
mais vous ferait le choix non pas de
cette imprudence masqué sous pseudonyme
mais d'incarner à visage découvert avec
mesure
cela fait deux semaines
que cet enlèvement a eu lieu
et deux par la procédure il faut
maintenant saisir un juge d'instruction
c'est celui qui a les meilleurs pouvoir
à ce moment là
monsieur
madame vous êtes
ce juge d'instruction vous reprenez
l'enquète en conscience vous aussi avec
professionnalisme et votre téléphone
sonne aussi les journalistes aimerait
vous entendre vous demandez ce qui
ressort des premières investigations
alors allez vous parler
non
parce que votre instruction est secrète
et parce que vous êtes nourrit des
histoires des exemples tristement
célèbre de notre histoire où la parole
judiciaire durant l'instruction a
complètement enrayé la recherche sereine
de la vérité
alors vous ne parlerez pas vos
informations resteront secrètes
et ses informations aboutissent à des
résultats
l'enfant est retrouvé vivant
et un suspect est interpellé
oserais-je dire
quelques années plus tard c'est le temps
du procès
madame vous allez présider cette
audience monsieur également
et vous le ferez sous les yeux des
caméras
dans la salle d'audience parce que
depuis quelques semaines la justice peut
être filmé dans des proportions sans
égard à ce qui était auparavant
et vous vous demandez en ouvrant votre
audience quel sera l'effet non pas des
yeux humains qui sont devant vous vous
en avez l'habitude mais de ses yeux
mécanique et de tous ceux qui charrie
alors les paroles fusent dans votre
prétoire voulaient modérer vous avez
cette présidence d'audience jusqu'à ce
qu'au final vous décidiez que l'audience
est suspendue
pour que vous alliez délibéré
pour délibérer vous vous retirez dans
une salle close à plusieurs et rien n'en
sortira jusqu'à votre verdict et dans
cette salle vous allez monsieur le
président madame la présidente
expérimenté l'angoissent décrite par
gide dans ses souvenirs de la cour
d'assises
parce qu'il se trouve que
de votre décision collective va naître
un résultat complètement inattendu ce
cela va
spectaculairement changé l'état du droit
existant
et vous pressentez que votre décision
sera
difficile à comprendre mais surtout pour
le public difficile à admettre
alors à ce moment là vous vous demandez
si vous avez le droit de prendre la
parole
d'aller au delà de la simple motivation
de votre décision mais de parler pour
l'expliquer
et en réfléchissant vous remarqué que la
cour de cassation fait désormais des
communiqués sur ses propres arrêt elle
les explique après les avoir rendus mais
en face
vous entendez ceux qui vous disent que
la loi ne vous prévoit pas cet espace de
paroles que vous risquez de contredire
la parole du parquet pire que vous
risquez de contredire votre propre
décision en parlant
alors vous peser le pour et le contre et
vous trancher c'est votre métier vous
allez parler
vous faites un communiqué de presse pour
expliquer votre décision parce que cette
décision aussi inattendu soit elle elle
est juridiquement fondée et elle mérite
d'être connue d'être comprise ou plutôt
le peuple au nom duquel elle est rendue
mérite de mieux la comprendre pour mieux
la juger lui-même
cinq années se sont écoulées depuis que
madame la présidente monsieur le
président vous avez pris cette parole
est encore des journaliste vous appelle
il aimerait savoir ce qui s'est joué
dans cette salle de délibéré quels ont
été les doutes les certitudes
et vous ne parlez pas là non plus
parce que ce qui se dit dans cette salle
et secret et ce secret doit être sacré
parce que c'est le prix de la liberté de
parole de chacun
toute cette expérience
vous leur ai vécu
dans votre carrière de juges de
procureurs des dizaines peut-être même
des centaines de fois
et à la fin de cette carrière
vous demeurerez avec des questions
peut-être même plus de questions que de
réponses
aurais-je dû dire autre chose aurais-je
dû me taire
aurais-je dû parler autrement
vous le voyez
être juge
procureur ce n'est pas simplement être
la bouche de la loi sans l'incarner
c'est être la voix du peuple
celle qui dit le droit
celle qui le crie parfois
celle qui fait que nous formons tous
ensemble une société
les responsabilités
sont immenses
comme les défis qui se dressent
alors
s'il y a un voeu que je forme ce soir
c'est que malgré ces défis malgré ses
responsabilités et peut-être même parce
qu'il y a des défis parce qu'il ya des
responsabilités
certaines certains d'entre vous
choisissent pour leur avenir de donner
de la voix en tant que magistrats
et peut-être
peut-on ensemble en excluant du bénéfice
du propos que je vais tenir
reconnaître
si ce n'est le courage au moins le
mérite
de ces femmes de ces hommes
qui donnent de la voix pour la justice
de notre pays
puis
face au pendule de foucault
qui lentement balance
laisser place au silence